So we just talked about how the evolution step in the case based reasoning
process when decided a correct solution in fact meets the requirements of
the given problem. Now that we have the new problem and the solution for
it, we can encapsulate them as a case, and store them in a case memory.
We saw the advantages of this kind of storage earlier,
when we went from home to restaurant. We stored that case is memory so that
when wanted to go back from restaurant to home. We could retrieve that case and
try to adapt it. So case choice is an important way of learning.
We are constantly accumulating and assimilating new cases. We talk
about two kinds of storage mechanisms. Indexing and discrimination crease.